اهلا بكم في هذه التغطيه المستمره
للتطورات في السودان وفي العناوين
في اليوم العاشر للمواجهات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع مصادر
للجزيره تكشف ان الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع يتجهان لهدنه جديده مدتها ثلاثه
ايام بعد اتصالات من الاداره الامريكيه
وفي المشهد تصاعد للمعارك في محيط مطار
الخرطوم والقصر الرئاسي وتبادل للتهامات
بالمسؤوليه عن الاضرار بمناطق سكنيه
مع حديث واشنطن عن احتمالات باستمرار
الصراع في السودان بالانكن يتحدث عن تواصل
مع دول بينها السعوديه والامارات للضغط
لانهاء القتال ويحذر من حضور فاجنر
واسرائيل تقترح استضافه محادثات بين
البرهان وحميدتي وجوتيريش يحذر الصراع في
السودان قد يمتد الى كامل المنطقه
نقص الغذاء والماء والادويه والوقود يرسم
صوره قاتمه للوضع الانساني في مناطق
السودانيه عديده الامم المتحده تقول ان
الامدادات الانسانيه والمستودعات تتعرض
لعمليات نهب منظمه الصحه العالميه تصف
الوضع الصحي بالمروعه مزيد من اللاجئين
نحو تشاد وجنوب السودان واثيوبيا هربا من
القتال وكاميرا الجزيره في ام درمان ترسل
صعوبه الاوضاع المعيشيه
سباق مع الزمن لاجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه من السودان بحرا
وبرا وجوا الامم المتحده تسحب مئات من
موظفيها وتبقي على رئيس بعثتها لمتابعه
الاوضاع في السودان عدد من الدول تتحدث عن
مخاطر تكتنف ترتيبات الاجلاء وترسل قطعا
بحريه وطائرات عسكريه
قالت مصادر لقناه الجزيره ان الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع يتجهان لهدنه
جديده لمده ثلاثه ايام وذلك بعد اتصالات
مع الاداره الامريكيه وفي اليوم العاشر
للاقتتال في السودان كان لافتا اليوم
امتداد المعارك الى احياء سكنيه فقد اتهمت
قوات الدعم السريع الجيش بتنفيذ غاره جويه
على احياء سكنيه متفرقه في الخرطوم ودانت
قوات الدعم السريع ما وصفته بالعمل
الغاشمي الذي يستهدف الابرياء ورد الجيش
السوداني على اتهامات الدعم السريع قائلا
ان مجموعات الدعم تتبعثر وسط الاحياء على
نطاق واسع للاحتماء بالتجمعات السكنيه
واتخاذ المواطنين دروعا بشريه كيف بدا
المشهد الميداني في الساعات الماضيه نتابع
في هذا العرض
[موسيقى]
اذا يعود الحديث في السودان عن هدنه جديده
رغم تهاوي الهدن السابقه الهدنه كما
تعرفها اتفاقيه جنيف الاولى في هذا العرض
[موسيقى]
نفس سفير المصري في السودان هاني صلاح نبا
مقتل مساعد ملحق الدفاع في السفاره في
اطلاق نار وسط العاصمه الخرطومه واكد
السفير في تصريحات نقلتها الصفحه الرسميه
لوزاره الخارجيه المصريه على الفيسبوك ان
جميع اعضاء البعث الدبلوماسيه المصريه
بخير وقد اصدر الجيش السوداني بيانا بشان
مقتل مساعد الملحق العسكري للسفاره
المصريه وقال انه يعتذر عن الخطا واوضح ان
الوظيفه الصحيحه للضحيه هي مساعد الملحق
الاداري للسفاره المصريه في الخرطوم
نشير لها الخبر العاجل بلينكن الوزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول ان اتفاق القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع على
تطبيق وقف اطلاق نار على مستوى البلاد
يبدا منتصف الليل 24 ابريل
ويستمر اثنين وسبعين ساعه هذه هي المهله
او الهدنه التي تم الحديث عنها لثلاثه
ايام وها هو ذا يعلنها وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتني بلنكن اذا الذي قام طبعا
بالاتصال بكل الاطراف وكانت هناك جهود
كبيره في الايام الماضيه ابرزها ربما كان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وها قد جاء
الاعلان عن هذه الهدنه على امل ان يتم
تنفيذها بالفعل على كل ينضم الينا من
جنوبي الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره الطاهر
المرضي من ام درمان مراسله الجزيره حسن
رزاق وراس الجزيره اسامه سيدي احمد اهلا
وسهلا بكم جميعا ابدا منك الطهر المرضي
اذا هذا ما جاء في الخبر العاجل 24 ابريل
منتصف الليل تبدا الهدنه هكذا يقول وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
نعم هذه هدنه جديده يستكشف بها السودانيون
خيرا ان كانت هذه الهدنه بها التزام كبير
وحرفي لوقف الطاقه النار لان الاوضاع هي
تتطلب هذا الامر من الناحيه الانسانيه
والميدانيه خاصه وان الهدنه التي كانت في
السابق لم يكن فيها الالتزام كافيا ولكن
الهدنه الجديده لربما تكون لديها جدوى
كبيره فيما يختص بالاوضاع الانسانيه
والظروف التي يعيشها السودانيون وهذه
الهدنه التي تم الاعلان عنها رسميا لربما
تتواصل بعد هذه الهدنه وخلال هذه الفتره
الزمنيه الاثنين وسبعين ساعه سيكون هنالك
نقاش لربما يتواصل فيه الطرفان برعايه
امريكيه لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار لان
نتحدث عن دوليه
على نتحدث عن يعني بعد ساعتين تقريبا تبدا
هذه الهدنه
بعد نعم
تدخل حيز التنفيذ وبالتالي تصبح من
الاجراءات المهمه في هذا الاطار
وان هذه الهدنه ربما تكون مدخل لوقف اطلاق
النار بحسب الذين تواصلنا معهم وكانت لهم
علاقات بهذه المشاورات يقولون ان خلال هذه
الهدنه ثلاثه ايام ستكون هنالك النقاشات
جده وحوارات مع طرفي هذا الصراع وصولا الى
وقف دائم لاطلاق النار والدخول في حوار
ينهي هذه الازمه خاصه وان التحذيرات
الدوليه والاقليميه كبيره والضغوط التي
تمارس على الطرفيه النظام
الصراع بان الاوضاع اذا صارت في هذا
الاتجاه سيفقد السودان وحدته واستقراره
وربما تكون هذه الحرب حرب شامله في هذه
المنطقه وهذا يهدد السلم والامن الدوليين
وبالتالي لابد لهذه الاطراف تستجيب
لنداءات الدوليه والمحليه خاصه وان
الاوضاع الانسانيه تحديدا هو النداءات
التي اطلقتها المتحده ومنظمات المجتمع
المدني يعني لا تزال الاوضاع الصعبه
للغايه المساعدات التي يمكن ان توصل لهذه
من الامم المتحده او ايا من الدول
المدنيين سواء كان على الجانب الغذائي او
حتى بالنسبه للدواء والصحه لا تجد طريقه
الى الدخول الى داخل السودان بسبب بان
اغلاق المطار مطار الخرطوم وان الصراع لم
يسمع حتى الان بتمريره حتى المسارات
الخاصه بالاسعافات الخاصه باصلاح او اعاده
الخدمه للمستشفيات التي خرجت عن الخدمه
وبالتالي هذه الامور تسير في هذا الاتجاه
ربما يكون لها عواقب ايجابيه في هذا
الاطار ننتظر ايضا تطبيق هذه الهدنه حسن
رزاق موجود فيهم درمان كيف تصف الوضع في
انتظار تطبيق هذه
الهدنه بعد ساعتين او اقل
عثمان وانا اتحدث اليك قبل دقائق من الان
كنت اسمع صوت كثيف لدوي لاصوات مضاد
طائرات وقذائف تنطلق من هذه المنطقه او
بالقرب من هذا المنطقه نتواجد فيها نامل
ان تكون هذه العاصفه التي يتبعها
هدوء ان كانت هناك التزام حقيقي بالهدنه
الكثير من المواطنين بداوا
تقل ثقتهم بالهدن المعنى لكن نامل ان كان
هناك وساطه
من دوله كبرى مثل امريكا ان تستمر هذه
الهدنه حسب ما هو متفق عليه على اي حال
عثمان نحن الان رصدنا بعضا من جوانب
المعاناه الانسانيه التي تعتبر احد
تداعيات الاستمرار المواجهات المسلحه كنا
اليوم في جوله في قطاع البنوك والمصارف
حيث اكتشفنا ان هناك اقفال كامل لكافه
البنوك والمصارف وحتى
اجهزه الصراف خاليه من اي سيوله نقديه
وهما اثر سلبا على تواجد النقديه بين يدين
مواطنين حتى يتدبر عملهم حتى يستطيعوا ان
يبتاعوا ما يحتاجونه من احتياجات من سلع
ومواد غذائيه هذا ايضا اثر على التضخم
الاسعار ارتفعت كلنا ايضا في جوله في احد
اكبر اسواق اندرمان والذي يعتبر المورد
الرئيسي للمحال الصغيره ومنافذ البيع في
الحارات وفي الاحياء من مواد وسلع كافه او
نقول اغلبيه هذه المحال مقفله ومن استطاع
ان يفتح ابوابه كانت
مواد التمويل قليله جدا وايضا باعتبار انه
سلاسل الامداد توقفت منذ اندلاع المواجهات
ما تسبب في تدافع المواطنين على شراء
السلع لتخزينها
بسبب مخاوف من يعني امد الحرب ان يطول
في ارتفاع الاسعار وبالتالي
نقص السيوله النقديه بين ايدي الناس ثبت
في اشكاليات كبيره حتى تطبيقات البنوك لا
تعمل في فترات طويله بالتالي نامل ان تكون
هذه الهدنه محل نفاذ اكثر من الاوقات
الماضيه عثمان بالفعل خاصه مع هذه الاوضاع
على الانسانيه الصعبه التي ذكرتها الا
بورسودان اذا اسامه سيدي احمد معظم عمليات
الاجلاء وهي على قدم وساق الان تمر عبر
بورسود
عثمان بالفعل يعني هذه العمليه التي
استمرت للحو ثلاثه ايام حتى الان التي
بدات الجمعه بعمليه تفريج 157
شخصا من رعايه الدول اجنبيه وعربيه هذه
العمليه بدات بالفعل وبين هذا الرقم
رعايه سعوديون بينهم ايضا
دبلوماسيون هذه العمليه تستمر عن طريق
ميناء بورسودان وايضا مطار بورسودان
الدولي لاول مره بدات عمليات الاجلاء امس
مساء
نحو
340 اردنيا بينهم دبلوماسيون عن طريق
طائرات اربع طائرات عسكريه وصلت بالفعل
الى عمان تليها مجموعه من العمليات
التفويج الرعايه دول الاجنبيه وعربيه
يصلون تباعا الى بورسودان عن طريق الطريق
القومي الرابط ما بين الخرطوم وفور
السودان ويمتد لنحو 1000 كيلومتر اعداد من
الاجانب والعرب هنا في مدينه بورسودان
يقيمون في مناطق متفرقه بدات عمليات
اجراءات
لتفويج واجلاء نحو 300 وخمسين من رعايه
الهند
سيركبون البحر صباحا على الارجح وعلى
سفينه حربيه الان موجوده في
في
ميناء بورسودان هذه العمليه بحسب قياده
البحر قياده البحر الاحمر العسكريه تقول
انها تقوم بتامينها بشكل كامل منذ يعني
بدايه انطلاق الرحله من الخرطوم الى مدينه
بورسودان في يعني تحدي كبير بالنسبه لها
هكذا تشير الى ان هذه العمليه ليست سهله
ولكن عازمه على ان تصل الى نهايتها عمليه
التامين التي تتحدث عنها القياده العسكريه
هنا تشمل الطائرات التي تقوم باجلاء هؤلاء
الذين يريدون الوصول الى دولهم
ونفس وهؤلاء الذين يصلون الى يريدون ان
تتم اجلائهم عمليه اجلائهم من مدينه
بورسودال هذه العمليه لا تزال مستمره لعده
ايام ما لم يتم الاعلان رسميا من الجهات
المختصه
بانهاء هذه قالت الجهات المختصه انها تعمل
نعم تعمل وفقه منظومه تشمل عدد من الجهات
المختصنه بشكل عام مستمره اذا شكرا لكم
جميعا اسامه سيدي احمد في بورسودان حسن
رزاق في ام درمان والطاهر المرضي كان معنا
من الخرطوم الجيش السوداني يمسكه بمفاصل
السيطره على اغلب مطارات البلاد بينما لم
تحسم السيطره بعد على مطار الخرطوم وتستمر
المواجهات حول عدد من المواقع
الاستراتيجيه والسياديه لاسيما في العاصمه
في العاصمه شكل مواجهه الميدانيه بعد عشره
ايام من المعارك نتابعه في هذا التقرير
يفرض نمط التسلح المتوفر لدى طرفي الصراع
في السودان التحرك الميدانيه والتكتيكات
القتاليه التي يتبعانها دون اخفاء لطبيعه
المناطق الجغرافيه التي تدور فيها
الاشتباكات الجيش السوداني ذو التسليح
النظمي الثقيل مع تفوق جوي يعمل على
السيطره بالطرق التقليديه للجيوش اما قوات
الدعم السريع فتتكل على تسليحها الخفيف
الذي يتيح لها تنفيذ عمليات كر وفر في
القتال الدائر يمكن الحديث عن مثلث مشتعل
يسعى كل طرف للسيطره او الحفاظ عليه مثلث
المطارات والموانئ والبقر السياديه
في العاصمه الخرطوم تتركز المواجهات على
ما يصطلح على تسميتها مواقع سياديه او
استراتيجيه
القصر الرئاسي وما يعنيه معنويا من سلطه
سياسيه مقر القياده العامه للجيش ودلالته
مقرا اساسيا للقوات المسلحه
مقر التلفزه الرسميه وغيرها العشرات
السيطره على هذه المواقع قد تشهي بان من
يمسك بها لديهم يضد طول ميدنيا في عاصمه
الدوله ومؤسساتها الضلع الثاني في
المعادله المطارات قوات الدعم السريعه
تتحرك نحو مطار مروي وتشتبك مع وحدات من
الجيش لايام قبل ان تنسحب
فالسيطره على المطار تعني حرمان الجيش
السوداني من بعض عناصر تفوقه الجوي اضافه
للحصول على نافذه يمكن استغلالها لاحقا في
اي دعم من وراء الحدود
ثم انتقلت قوات الدعم السريع لمحاوله
السيطره على مطار الخرطوم الذي يضم قاعده
عسكريه ايضا لم تحسم المعركه حوله بعد
فجوغرافيا المطار ممتده في منطقه مفتوحه
وبالتالي يسهل رصد اي تحرك هاجمت قوات
الدعم السريع ايضا مطار الاوبيض ذا الموقع
استراتيجي الذي يتوسط العاصمه واقليم
دارفور ومنطقه ابيه الغنيه بالنفط مطار
الفاشر في ولايه شمال دارفور يقع ضمن
مناطق نفوذ واسعه للدعم السريع لكن الجيش
متكلا على تفوقه الجوي بسطه سيطرته عليه
اما مطار نيالا في ولايه جنوب دارفور
فتسيطر عليه قوه الدعم السريع المعركه على
المواقع الاستراتيجيه تشمل ايضا القتال
حول الموانئ التي تعتبر ضروريه نظرا
لسهوله نقل المؤن والمساعدات العسكريه
عبرها وبكميات اكبر مما قد ينقل جوا
تنتشر على الساحل السوداني موانئ عده
بورسودان اهمها واكبرها اخفقت قوات الدعم
السريع في السيطره عليه ويستخدم حاليا
قاعده اساسيه في اشلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
معنى من الخرطوم الفريق فتح الرحمن محي
الدين قائد قوات البحريه السودانيه السابق
سنه الفريق الان تم اعلان هدنه
اعلنها وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ويفترض ان
تبدا بعد ساعه واربعين دقيقه تقريبا ما
فرص ونجاحها في رايك
المشاهدين
انا اعتقد انه يعني
نج
اح ايضا
سيكون ضعيفا خاصه وان يعني من الواضح جدا
ان الان عناصر التمدد يعني
ليس هنالك قدره لتوصيل التعليمات
المنسوبيها
المنسوبيل تمرد الان ينتشرون في شوارع
الاحياء ينتشرونه وسط السكان بطريقه يعني
فيها شيء من العشوائيه وبالتالي انا اعتقد
انه التعليمات لم تصل اليهم لكن لكن يعني
الشيء الملاحظ مثلا اليوم لم تكن هنالك
ولكن لو ضحك كانت يعني
مستقره الاشتباكات كانت قليله
نسبيا نظام حتى بالايام اللي كانت فيها
وبذلك
المسلحه الان مهتمه بتامين اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب والدبلوماسيين
يعني لا تصاعد من عملياتها كثيرا خاصه في
المنطقه الحيويه التي صنعها هذه الفساد
الدبلوماسيه وفي الاتجاهات اللي بيتم من
خلال الاخلاص اذا كانت طرق البريه او
الطرق المؤديه الى
الامور التي تثير الاست
غراب الفريق من الامور التي استغراب ان
الجهه التي تتحدث عن عن تحقيق تقدم في
وساطتها بين الطرفين هي اسرائيل اليس هذا
غريبا
قياسا بتاريخ السودان في في القضيه
الفلسطينيه وعلاقه السودان باسرائيل
علاقه مع اسرائيل او خلاف اسرائيل الموضوع
انه القوات المسلحه حريصه على تنفيسه
تركتني كنت اكمل لك الفكره انه هذا
المسلحه للتامين طرق الاجلال للدبلوماسيين
الشيء الاخر داعيه لتوصيل الخدمات
للمواطنين يعني لا زال هنالك احيانا هذه
هذه النقطه
واضحه الفريق هذه النقطه واضحه ولكن انا
سؤالي لك انا سؤالي لك تحديدا عن الدوري
الاسرائيلي لانه لانه يتم الحديث فيه بشكل
معلن ورسمي وفي اتصال يقول الاسرائيليون
بالطرفين بقائد قوات الدعم السريع
المسلحه والدعم السريع لم يقولوا نحن
قبلنا بالهدنه بواسطه اسرائيليه وانما
قالوا ببساطه امريكيه يعني الوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
بناء على الاتصال
رغم التطبيع الذي سعى اليه الفريق الاول
عبد الفتاح البرهان مع الكيان الصهيوني
لكن
الموضوع يعني
مطلقا ولا اتوقع انه يكون هو سبب
شكرا جزيلا لكم الفريق فتح الرحمن محي
الدين قائد القوات البحريه السودانيه
السابق ومعنا من الخرطوم الجميل الفاضل
الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك اسالك ايضا اذا
ما كانت هناك فرصه حقيقيه لهذه الهدنه في
التطبيق وتنفيذ لثلاثه ايام كما قال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
رقم رغم فشل التجارب السابقه في اعلان وقف
اطلاق نار مؤقت او هدنه وليست المره
الاولى ايضا بطلب من وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلانكن لم يحالف هذه
التجارب والذي سبقت نجاح يذكر لكن يبدو
الان هناك على الارض وضع مختلف هذا اليوم
يعتبر من الايام التي شهدت نوع من الهدوء
النسبي عدا بعد الطلعات الجويه في مناطق
جنوب الخرطوم لكن مركز الذي تدور فيه
المعارك التكتيكيه بشكل منتظم القصر
الرئاسي القياده العامه
منطقه المطار احياء في مدينه بحري حله حمد
وحلت خوجلي وشامبات هذا المحور ظل اليوم
في حاله من الهدوء النسبي لكن انا اتصور
ان ربما ان هناك علاقه مع ما بينما رشح عن
المبادره الاسرائيليه
والخبر الذي نشرته اكسيوس ايضا عن الطلبه
الامريكي لاسرائيل بالتدخل في ملف الحرب
في السودان وفي تقدير ان الولايات المتحده
ترغب في ان تجعل لاسرائيل
سبت تقدم للسودانيين وليس ليس هذا تقريبا
يعني اليس هذا غريبا بالنسبه للمشاهد اليس
هناك غرابه في هذا الموضوع بالنسبه
للمشاهد العربي والسوداني ايضا ان تكون
اسرائيل مرشحه لدور للعب دور من هذا النوع
وكما قلت مع ضيفنا السابق مع الطرفين
ولا يوجد تعليق او نفي من سواء الفريق
البرهان او الفريق حميد
نوع من الواضح تماما ان الاصابع
الاسرائيليه ودور المخابرات الاسرائيليه
في التغلقل داخل الاجهزه السودانيه هو دور
بلغ شاو بعيد وانه دور ليس بجديد وان هناك
شخوص ما صعدوا في مسرح السياسه السودانيه
ربما يكون لاسرائيل ايضا دور خفي في ابراز
وتقديم بعض الشخصيات لان حالهما تولى
الجنرال عبد الفتاح البرهان رئاسه المجلس
العسكري الانتقالي وتوقيع الاتفاق مع اقوى
الحريه والتغيير في السابع عشر من اغسطس
في العام 2019 في الثالث من فبراير في
العام 2020 بعد سته اشهر تقريبا من تولي
منصب رئاسه المجلس هذا الانتقالي فاجعل
الجميع بزياره الى ينتبه لاغنديه بدعوه من
الرئيس اليوغندي بيوريوسيفيني وبوساطه من
مستشارته السودانيه الاصل نجوى قدح الدم
اعتقد اشاره
الى اي مدى وجميل الفاضل نعم هذا زياره
معروفه ولكن الكلام ربما بالاشاره الى
السيد حمادتي ايضا واتصالاته بالجانب
الاسرائيلي كما يقول الاسرائيليون وليس
هناك نفي الان من جانب حميد
نعم صحيح انا اعتقد ان كلا الرجلين لهما
علاقات
بالاجهزه الاسرائيليه ربما علاقات عبد
الفتاح البرهان كانت اسبق حتى اشاره كتبها
الكاتب الصحفي فتح الضوء واصدر مؤلف اسمه
اشعار الى ان العلاقه ما بين عبد الفتاح
البرهان كضابط في الجيش السوداني والنظام
الاسرائيلي بدات اثناء عمله في اقليم
دارفور ايضا انا لا ادري مدى صحه هذه
المعلومه لكنها وردت في كتابه وهي موثقه
واشارت الى الشخص الذي لعب هذا الدور من
قبل المخابرات الاسرائيليه ربما تجد شواهد
على الارض تؤكد ان هذه العلاقه ترجمه تم
ترجمتها حاله ما وصل عبد الفتاح البرهان
الى ذروه سلامه السلطه في العام 2020 شكرا
ودون مقدمات تذكر اما بالنسبه لمحمد حمدان
دقلو معلوم معلوم ان الرجل الثاني في قوات
الدعم السريعه قد عرف بزياره لاسرائيل وان
هناك دعم نعم وهناك دعم لمحمد حمدان دقله
باجهزه وتكنولوجيا اتصالات وتجسس هذا كله
قد رشح لم يصدر نفي من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع لوجود هذا يؤكد ان الرجلين لهم
علاقه ثم نعم شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطومه
الجميله الفاضل الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
سياسيا اذا تشكل او تتشكل ملامح حراك
دوليا من اجل وقف المعارك فقد قال وزير
الخارجيه انتني بلينكن بلاده بذلت جهودا
لانهاء القتال في السودان وفي مؤتمر مع
نظيره الكيني عبر عبر الوزير الامريكي عن
قلق بلاده بشان دوري مجموعه فاغنر في
السودان وفي بلدان افريقيه اخرى
ينال الشيخ
ستعمل الولايات المتحده مع جميع الاطراف
بالتنسيق مع الشركاء الاقليميين والدوليين
لانهاء القتال في السودان والعوده الى
الانتقال لحكومه مدنيه نتواصل بشكل مباشر
مع البرهان واحمد للضغط عليهما لتمديد
وتوسيع هدنه عيد الفطر لتصبح وقفا نهائيا
ودائما للاعمال العدائيه
كان ذلك قبل الاعلان اعلان بلانكا عن
التوصل لاتفاق لتطبيق وقفه اطلاق النار في
الساعه 12 الليله في السودان وكان بلين
قال ايضا الى واشنطن على تواصل مستمر مع
شركائها في المنطقه وخارجها من اجل التوصل
الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار في السودان
تواصلنا ميرانا خلال هذه الازمه مع مجموعه
من الدول وتحدثت بشكل مباشر مع نظراء في
السعوديه والامارات كما تواصل اعضاء من
فريق مع مصر ودول اخرى والمملكه المتحده
لتحقيق نفس الهدف وهو التوصل الى وقف
لاطلاق النار ووقف للاعمال العدائيه
واعاده البلاد الى مسار الانتقال الى
حكومه مدنيه
اما وزير الخارجيه الكيمي الفريد موتو
فعبر عن قلق بلاده اذا تدخل اطراف خارجيه
في النزاع في السودان
فيما يخص التدخل المباشر لبعض المجموعات
كنا قلقين للغايه من بعض اصدقائنا في
الشرق الاوسط وكما وردنا ان روسيا واخرين
تربطهم علاقات طويله الامد بالجانبين نقول
لهم انه ليس الوقت المناسب للانحياز الى
اي جانب في الحرب حان الوقت لجمع الطرفين
لان السلامه يجب ان يسود في نهايه الامر
ويجب ان ينعم الشعب السوداني بالاستقرار
تصريحات وبيانات ومؤتمرات صحفيه عبر
القارات متشابهه في صياغتها وفي الفشل على
الارض في اخماد نار تحرق بلدا بما فيه
عشره ايام والدبلوماسيه الاقليميه
والدوليه تتفرج على التراجيديا الاقتتال
والتدمير في عاصمه
تلك الجهود هو اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب من
السودان ماذا عن الضغوط لوقف اطلاق نار
مستدام ووضع السلاح والجلوس الى طاوله
الحوار قبل فوات الاوان هي في مرحله
الدعوات غير المستجابه والاتصالات التي
تنتهي بوعود تحترم من طرفي الصراع السباق
نحو اغلاق السفارات اليس استسلاما ونذيرا
بان العالم رفع يديه عما حدث وسيحدث مع
توقع اتساع رقعه الكارثه
[موسيقى]
جهود رقب الصدع واحتواء الازمه لم تتوقف
اجمعت معظم التصريحات الاخيره من كل
المشهد المعقد والدام في السودان قلقوا
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي من مجموعه فاغنر
حاضرا في اغلب المؤتمرات الصحفيه مؤكدا
استمرار الاتصالات مع طرفي الاقتتال لنعرف
ستعمل الولايات المتحده مع جميع الاطراف
بالتنسيق مع الشركاء الاقليميين والدوليين
لانهاء القتال في السودان والعوده الى
الانتقال لحكومه المدنيه من جهته دعا
الامين العام للامم المتحده اعضاء مجلس
الامن الدولي الى استخدام اقصى درجات
نفوذهم لانقاذ السودان من الهاويه
يجب ان يتوقف العنف انه يهدد باندلاع
مواجهه كارثيه داخل السودان يمكن ان تبتلع
المنطقه باكملها وما وراءها انني ادين
بشده القصف العشوائيه للمناطق المدنيه بما
في ذلك مرافق الرعايه الصحيه وادعو
الاطراف الى وقف العمليات القتاليه في
المناطق المكتظه بالسكان والسماح بعمليات
المساعده الانسانيه دون عوائق
باريس التي تشرف على اجلاء رعايه عده دول
عبر جيبوتي جددت دعوتها لجميع الاطراف الى
وقف المعارك وجاء في بيان الخارجيه ان
فرنسا تحشد طاقاتها لتسهيل وقف اطلاق
النار واستئناف عمليه الانتقال السياسي في
السودان بعد وصفه لما يجري بحاله الفوضى
والعنف الهائل شدد وزير الدوله البريطاني
للشؤون الافريقيه على ضروره دفع جانبين
الى القاء السلاح في لوكسمبورغ وقبل دخول
قاعه الاجتماع وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي ثم المسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد جوزيف جهود الدول التي اسهمت في
عمليات الاجلاء الناجحه رغم صعوبتها وذكر
الصحفيين ان الاسره الدوليه قادره على
مواصله الضغوط على الطرفين لوقف الحرب
في زمن الانقلابات والتقلبات من كل نوع
تعلن تل ابيب انها اقترحت استضافه محادثات
بين طرفي الصراع بين وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي رصاصه اخرى في مشهد لا ينقصه
البارود قال انه منذ اندلاع القتال تعمل
اسرائيل عبر قنوات مختلفه من اجل التوصل
الى وقف لاطلاق النار والتقدم الذي جرى
احرازه خلال الايام القليله الماضيه في
المحادثات مع الجانبين وعد جدا على حد
تعبيره فهي مصائب قوم عند قوم فوائد ام
سياسه انتهاز الفرص حتى لو كانت ملطخه
بالدم محنه السودان تكبر مع كل يوم اخر في
صراع يتاجر به الاخوه الاعداء واعداء
الامس واليوم من يراف ببلد حل به هرب
وجلاء ودنك وبلاء ونار مضطرمه وفتنه
محتدمه
من مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك شيرين
ياسين مساعده المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده تنضم الينا اهلا وسهلا بك
لا شك ان هناك الكثير مما يجب فعله
وترغبون في فعله في السودان على ماذا
تتركز جهود الامم المتحده الان
اهلا وشكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه بالفعل هي
محنه كبيره هي كارثه ما يحدث الان في
السودان هناك حاجه ماسه الى وقف اطلاق
النار الى وقف العنف الى وضع السلاح جانبا
كما دعى الامين العام صباح هذا اليوم في
مجلس الامن على تلك الدول التي لديها نفوذ
على الاطراف ان تمارس ذلك النفوذ من اجل
الضغط على تلك الاطراف لوقف العنف
المساعدات الانسانيه هي اولويه كبيره
بالنسبه للامم المتحده لكن تم تعطيلها في
العديد من المناطق وذلك بسبب اعمال النهب
اعمال السرقه ايضا
قتل ثلاثه من
طواقم برنامج الاغذيه العالمي كما تعلمون
في الاسبوع الماضي في احداث الاسبوع
الماضي المؤسفه وهو ما عطل تقديم تلك
المساعدات الى السودانيين ولذلك فهناك
حاجه ماسه اولا وقبل كل شيء الى ممارسه
الضغط من اجلي وقف اطلاق النار نعم كانت
هناك تقارير كثيره تحدث ت عن عمليات سلب
ونهب يتعرض لها
المواطنون ولكن ايضا ربما مقرات تابعه لكم
هل يمكنك ان تطلعين على مزيد من التفاصيل
التي وردتكم في هذا الاطار
كنا بانتظار طبعا مهله او وقف او وقفه
لانسانيه لما يحدث من عنف حتى يتم تقييم
الوضع وحتى يتم
معرفه ما الذي حدث تماما ما هي الخسائر
كيف يمكن
استئناف تقديم المساعدات في ظل ما يحدث
فكان من الضروري وجود تلك الوقفه
الانسانيه لكن وضعنا سلامه تواقم الامم
المتحده
كاولويه
وتم انتهاز فرصه وقف اطلاق النار التي
حدثت في العيد من اجل النقل المؤقت لعدد
من من طواقمنا الى مناطق اخرى داخل
السودان ولذلك فلا يزال التقييم قائما حتى
الان نعم يعني انتم الان سوف تقومون
بتوفير امدادات معينه هل بامكانكم ان
توفروا الحمايه لهذه الامدادات في ظل ما
يحدث في هذه الحاله الامنيه المترديه
هو وضع متردي بلا شك ووضع كارثي للغايه تم
الاعلان صباح اليوم عن انشاء مركز في
مدينه بورت سودان
وستظل بعض توقمنا موجوده في ذلك المركز
سيكون ممثلا الامين العام للامم المتحده
موجود في ذلك المركز
الاولويه كما ذكرت لك هي لوقف اطلاق النار
حتى يتسنى تقديم المساعدات لملايين
الاشخاص الوضع الانساني في السودان كان
سيئا ومترديا حتى قبل اندلاع القتال فما
بالك الان بعد اندلاع القتال برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه على سبيل المثال كان
ينوي تقدير مساعدات الى اكثر من سبعه
ملايين شخص هذا العام والان تعطلت هذه
البرامج تعطلت برامج كثيره الامم المتحده
تدعم برامج ليس فقط تابعه للمتحده ولكن
ايضا للشركاء
والعديد من تلك البرامج تعطلت ولذلك فنحن
نناشد الاطراف وقف اطلاق النار من اجل ان
يتسنى تقديم المساعدات الى من هم في امس
الحاجه اليها هل لكم اي دوره تلعبونه في
وقف اطلاق النار في تنفيذ الهدنه من خلال
المراقبه ربما من خلال اليات معينه
حتى الان كل الجهود تتركز كما راينا منذ
الاسبوع الماضي حتى منذ اليوم الاول من
اندلاع القتال وكان الامين العام قد اجرى
اتصالاته مع الطرفين وايضا مع القاده
الاقليميين مع الاتحاد الافريقي ومع ايجاد
من اجل التوصل الى هدنه طبعا الوضع
النموذجي والمثالي هو وقف كامل وشامل
لاطلاق النار ووضع السلاح جانبا هو تنفيذ
ما يرغب به السودانيون وهو انتقال سلمي
وان يعيشوا في سلام في بلدهم هذا هو الهدف
الاسمى وايضا كان الامين العام لا يزال
على اتصالات مستمره من اجل ايجاد طريق
وسبيل لوقف اطلاق النار تماما في ذلك
البلد شكرا جزيلا لك من مقر الامم المتحده
في نيويورك شيرين ياسين مساعده المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
في الاثناء اعلنت اسرائيل اليوم انها
اقترحت استضافه محادثات بين قائدي طرفي
النزاع في السودان لوقف اطلاق النار واوضح
وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيليه لكوهين ان
اسرائيل تعمل منذ اندلاع القتال في
السودان عبر قنوات مختلفه من اجل التوصل
لوقف لاطلاق النار مشيرا الى ان التقدم
الذي تحقق خلال الايام القليله الماضيه في
المحادثات مع الجانبين واحد جدا وكان
موقعه قال في وقت سابق ان الاداره
الامريكيه اطلعت على المقترح الاسرائيلي
بشان الوساطه وان اسرائيل نسقت جهودها
معها ومع دول في المنطقه منها الامارات
من واشنطن ينضم الينا الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه دكتور خليل لهذا ما يقوله وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي وليس يعني طرف مغمور
مثلا في اسرائيل ولا يوجد اي نفي لهذا من
الطرفين سواء طرف الجيش الفريق البرهان او
طرف حماتي والدعم السريع الا توجد غرابه
في هذا الموضوع ان تقوم اسرائيل بالذات
بهذا الدور يعني لماذا اسرائيل وليس غير
غير اسرائيل
لا اعتقد ذلك هذا عثمان ليس هناك اغراب
على الاطلاق اولا السودان عباره عن ساحه
مفتوحه لكل الدول الاقليميه والدوليه
تحاول ان تلعب دور مهم في دول في دوله
غنيه دوله زي موقع استراتيجي في نفس الوقت
دوله ضعيفه ليس لديها نظام حكم قوي
وبالتالي هناك اغراء التعاطي مع باعتبارها
غنيمه اسرائيل لديها ليها طموح كبير جدا
في لعب دور مهم جدا في ما يحدث الان في
السودان لدي علاقات قويه جدا بطرفي النزاع
نتذكر فقط انه على مدار اربع سنوات هناك
علاقات مستمره وعينيك زيارات مستمره سواء
لضباط المثلث الاسرائيلي الى السودان هناك
اللقاءات تمت على اعلى مستوى مع البرهان
ومع حمدت مسؤولين اسرائيليين فقط في
فبراير الماضي السودان وتحدث عن احتمال
توقيع اتفاق السلام مع السوداني خلال
الشهور القادمه وكان هناك توقع بانه عندما
يتم الانتهاء من تسليم الحكومه المدنيين
ان يتم توقيع الاتفاق خلال الشهور القادمه
لم يحدث وبالتالي هناك مطامع اسرائيليه
هناك دور وفاعل ما جاء اليوم يؤكد كان
هناك اختراق اسرائيل واضح جدا للنخب
العسكريه
السودانيه هناك علاقات قويه جدا مع حماتي
حماتي حسب كثير من الانباء التقى بطبات
المشاهده الاسرائيلي اكثر من مره اخوه عبد
الرحيم دجل وزاره تل ابيب قبل حوالي
اسبوعين انقلاب 2021 وبالتالي هناك علاقه
قويه جدا بين هذا الذي حدث وبين على زياره
الاسرائيليات قويه جدا الطرفين ليس
مستغربا تكون الصليب بدون الوساطه والدعوه
لذلك من اجل استثمار وجودها هناك هناك
مصالح اسرائيليه في السودان سواء كان
مصالح سياسيه متعلقه بالتطبيع سواء متعلقه
باستغلال على الاقل 48 كيلو متر على البحر
الاحمر من اجل دعم وجوده تلك المرتق منطقه
افريقيا
لديها وجود في افريقيا على مدار 20 سنه
تغلغل في افريقيا
مع السودان
كدعم استخبارات دعم
اسرائيل لحلفائها في السودان دور العربي
لاسيما يعني اكيد هناك دول تربطها علاقات
قويه
ووثيقه بالسودان ولها مصالح وكل ما الى
ذلك لم يكن وردا ان يقوم بهذا الدور طرف
عربي مثلا اسرائيل
لابد ان نفرق بين امرين بين دعوه للوساطه
ومحاوله تهديه الاوضاع بين يعني تحول ذلك
الى فعل حقيقه معنى اخر هناك استجابه فعله
لذلك قد يكون جزء من هذه المساله دعايه
اسرائيليه فيما يتعلق بالدول العربي مختفي
منذ عقود الدول العربيه في حاله ضعف في
حاله هشاشه الانظمه العربيه نفسها في حاله
تطبيع مع اسرائيل سواء تطبيع رسمي او غير
رسمي الطرف الوحيد المؤثر العربي في
السودان هو الامارات وطبعا لاسباب خاصه
بها الامارات لديها وجود اقتصادي ومالي
وعسكري تدعم طرف مقابل طرف في السودان
لديها استثمارات في السودان تتجاوز سبعه
ثمانيه مليار دولار لديه اجنده خاصه بتمدد
في المنطقه سواء تتقرن الافريق عندها
علاقات قويه جدا مع جيبوتي مع اريتريا مع
اثيوبيا وايضا في في الشمال الغربي
للسودان لديه علاقات قويه مع حفتر في
ليبيا باستثناء الامارات ليس هناك دور
دوله عربيه اخرى على نفس القوه للاسف
الشديد مصر على سبيل المثال منتفع على
ذاتها مشغوله بمشكله الداخليه تبدو
مطورتها بشكل باخر في دعم البرهان مقابل
حمدتي لديها سياسات خطيئه فبتعلق في
السودان وبالتالي هناك
باختصار هناك حاله فراغ عربي كبيره جدا
تدفع بدوله اسرائيل ان تكون بدور هذا
الفراغ وبالتالي ليس مستغربا ليس هناك دور
عربي مؤثر طبعا يعتبر نوع من انواع
التراجع العربي لحد بعيد فيما يتعلق في
السودان
شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه حدثنا
من واشنطن
من جهه قال وزير الخارجيه جنوب السودان
دينك داون الجزيره ان بلاده تتواصل مع
طرفي النزاع في السودان وتضغط من اجل
التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار مؤكدا ان
التطورات الحاليه تثير مخاوف الجباء
وذكردا وان الاتحاد الافريقي يبذل جهودا
لوقف النزاع وانه شكل فريقه وسطاء سيجري
قريبا مباحثات في الخرطوم مع البرهان
وحميتي
اتفق الاتحاد الافريقي مع منظمه ايجاد على
تشكيل فريق من ثلاثه مسؤولين رفيعي
المستوى للدخول في مباحثات مع السودان
وسيزور ثلاثتهم الخرطوم حين يستقر الوضع
ويصير المطار مهيئا لاستقبالهم لبدء
مشاورات مع البرهان والسيد حميدتي وقد عقد
الاتحاد الافريقي اجتماعا حضره شركاء
الدوليون لمناقشه الوضع الحالي ومساعده
اطراف النزاع على وقف اطلاق النار
واستئناف المفاوضات
ينضم الينا من لندن احمد سليمان كبير
الباحثين في برنامج القرن الافريقي في
معهد شاتم مع السيد سليمان الى اين وصلت
الجهود الافريقيه بالتحديد في السودان
لدينا خليط من
الجهود وربما اي اهم المحاولات الوساطه
يجري التنظيمها باليه ثلاثيه تجمع
الاتحاد الافريقي والمجموعه
والامم المتحده واضافه الى هناك جهود
اقليميه وايضا عن طريق ايجاد رئيس الكيني
وجنوب السودان والجيبوتي ثلاثه رؤساء ولكن
ما نشهده اي من هذه هذه المبادرات
المنعزله غير كافيه
جهود نزيد من التنسيق
التحرك الدولي وقد هناك اجتماع مجموعه 25
محادثات متعدده الطرف تحت رئاسه رئيس
مفوضيه اتحاد الافريقي
قضيه الجامعه العربيه والاتحاد الاوروبي
والايجاد وبالتالي هناك فهم عام بانه هناك
ضروره ان تبذل جهود مشتركه من قبل عده
شركاء لمحاوله تغيير ما يجري على الارض
على عياده جماعه حمدي
البرهان نعم تم الحديث عن
الرئيس الرئيس جنوب السودان والرئيس
الكيني والرئيس جيبوتي وطبعا هذه الزياره
لم تتم بسبب الاوضاع التي لا تسمح بذلك
ولكن هل الافارقه تاثير حقيقي
بالفعل يمكن ان يكونوا مؤثرين فعلا ام هو
كلام من قبيل يعني الجوار والنوايا الطيبه
وما الى ذلك من ام
هذه التصريحات اللي هو الشيء ولكن المهم
ان يتبعها اجراء ملموس على الارض لحد الان
لم نجد اي شريك استطاع لحد الان ان ينزل
يصل الى الموقع الى
الجهود الوساطه اي الجلوس الى الجنرلين
البرهان وحميتي لبدء بالعمليه لكن في
نهايه المطاف حسب رايي اعتقد ان بعض اصحاب
العلاقه الاقليميه في البيئه الاوسع
السواع في الشوارع افريقيا والشرق الاوسط
مصر مثلا الامارات العربيه المتحده
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه هذه الدول
الثلاثه بشكل خاص لديهم تاثير ونفوذ كبير
على الطرفين واعتقد انهم لو كان هناك اي
جهد منسخ يشمل سيؤدي الى النفوس كبير من
قبل هذه الدول هذا من شان ان يؤدي الى بعض
التحرك ولكن
تواصلهم في العمليه السياسيه هو في
السودان كان متناقضا في الواقع حتى
تنافسيا فيما بينهم مما يقل الامكانات
تخفيف التصعيد وحل النزاع سلميا شكرا
جزيلا لك من لندن احمد سليمان كبير
الباحثين في برنامج القرن الافريقي في
معهد شاتم
في الاثناء قالت دكتور احمد المنظر المدير
الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه العالميه للشرق
المتوسط قال للجزيره ان الوضع الصحيه في
السودان مقلق ومروع جدا واضاف ان المنظمه
تناشدت داعمين الدوليين توفير مليار و700
مليون دولار للسودان
هناك ما يقارب من حوالي 50 الف طفل يعانون
من نقص تغذيه حاد ويحتاجون الى عنايه يعني
متواصله خلال 24 ساعه ولاسابيع لاستعاد
عافيتهم هناك ما يقارب من 24 الف امراه
سودانيه نتوقع عن يعني
تكون في وضع الولاده خلال الاسابيع
القادمه معرضات للخطر ولا قدر الله للوفاه
بسبب اغلاق المؤسسات الصحيه وكذلك عدم
مقدرتهم الوصول الى المؤسسات التي هي
مفتوحه هناك ما يقارب من واحد واربعه من
عشره مليون يعني امراه وفتاه معرضات كذلك
لمشاكل صحيه هناك مخاطر ظهور فاشيات كحمه
ضنك والملاريا وشلل الاطفال
اصاب شلل تام في هذه الاثناء الحركه
التجاريه في اسواق مدينه ام درمان واغلقت
المصارف ابوابها جراء استمرار المواجهه
المسلحه في المدينه كاميرا الجزيره ترصد
معاناه السودانيين في ظل نقص المواد
والسلع الاساسيه وما ترتب عن ذلك من
ارتفاع في الاسعار وشحن في السيوله
النقديه
شلل تام ضرب القطاع المصرفيه بالعاصمه
الخرطوم جراء المواجهات المسلحه
فجميع البنوك هنا اغلقت ابوابها ما تسبب
في شح كبير في السيوله النقديه لدى
المواطنين ومن يوم السبت
البنوك وقفه والكهرباء والمويه الناس
معاني هنا بس الناس اللي قاعدين حراسات
كلهم الناس في حاله بتاعه عدم استقرار
لانه البلد مؤمن
الشلل التهامي انعكس ايضا على سوق ام
درمان الشهير الذي يعد المزود الرئيسيه
لدكاكين الاحياء بالسلع والمواد
الاستهلاكيه وسط هذا الاغلاق يظهر هذا
الدكان كبارقه امل لكن صاحبه يشتكي من ان
بضاعته اوشكت على النفاد
من يوم السبت لليوم ما في حاجه خشب عندنا
في الدكاكين اللي على المخازن دي شغالين
فيها
المواطنين من طول امد الحرب دفعتهم لشراء
السلع بكميات كبيره لتخزينها ما تسبب في
ارتفاع الاسعار يعني
الاسعار غاليه والله بصراحه وما في ذاته
مفاتيح
لكن برضو بس لنا
محمد حمدان
يجلسوا يشوفوا قال بيبقى شنو
لانه البلد ده كده بينهار وبمشي باسوه لا
تمثل مناشدات الطيب استثناء في هذه
المدينه فالجميع هنا يدفعون ثمن حرب
يجهلون مالاتها
قيظ للمواطنين هنا ان يقعوا في امتحان
امتحان لا يملك المرء امامه سوى ان يتمسك
بالامل ففي ظل استمرار المواجهات المسلحه
باتت كل القصص تحذر من كارثه انسانيه
وشيكا حسن رزاق الجزيره اندرمان
برنامج افريقيا في منظمه رفيجيز
انترناشونال طبعا المنظمات الدوليه
المختصه بهذا العمل هي مضطره للعمل في
ظروف من هذا النوع في الظروف الصعبه في
الظروف الحروب كيف تتمكن من مساعده
المواطنين العالقين والذين يعانون معاناه
شديده في هذه الظروف كيف يتم هذا العمل
هناك عمل كثير جرت قيام به في السودان حتى
قبل هذه القتال هناك
سته عشر مليون شخص وكانوا بالساعه حاجه
الى مساعدات غذائيه وبالتالي في هذه
الظروف القتال اصبح الامر اكثر صعوبه نجد
ان برنامج الغذاء العالمي ومنظمات
غير حكوميه دوليه اوقفت اعمالها وكانت
هناك بعد خاصه بعد قتل ثلاثه من العماله
الغاثه في دارفور وبالتالي اعتقد ان هناك
التدهور كبير في الوضع في خرطوم بشكل خاص
ومناطق اخرى ايضا حيث الناس يبدو
اتباع في منازلهم ثم بعد ذلك يحاولون
الهروب وبالتالي الشعب وشاهدنا المستشفى
الوضع صعب وكل ما الى ذلك ولكن سؤالي لك
انا اود ان تشرح لنا هل عمل هذه المنظمات
يستمر في هذه الظروف كيف تعمل كيف توصل
المساعدات الى المحتاجين في ظل الظروف
الامنيه الصعبه لان هذا عملها بالاساس ان
تعمل في ظروف صعبه من هذا النوع
نعم باختصار العمل صعب جدا استمرار فيه
صعب جدا واحيانا لا يمكن حتى الاستمرار
فيه عندما لا يكون لديك ان تكون طرق
مسدوده وعندما كناك خطوط امتدادات مقطوعه
يسعى الامر صعبا جدا وخاصه الذين يوصلون
هذه المواد من السودانيين او من موظفين
العالميين من السودانيين وغير السودانيين
عملهم يصلح خطيرا جدا وبالتالي لابد هناك
وقف اطلاق نار
يدوم يستمر
اذا سمحت لي ان اركز السؤال اكثر ربما اذا
كان طرفاء الصراع يقولان انهما حريصان على
مصلحه المواطن وبالتالي ما المطلوب من
الطرفين لتعمل منظمات الاغاثه الانسانيه
لابد ان هناك اولا توقف القتال ورفع الطرق
المغلقه او ما هو موجود في الشوارع لكن
تستطيع المنظمات لقيام بعملها وتسليم
وايضا هناك حاجه لاعاده بناء بعض البنى
التحتيه التي تدمرت
لتوفير المياه الصالحه للشرب او الدخول
الى الوصول الى المستشفيات لكن اول شيء
ينبغي هو انه على الاقل الحد الادنى من
المطلوب هو ايقاف العمليات القتال
واستهداف المناطق المدنيه
محلات ايصال للمياه ثم السماح بالجميع
المنظمات
للوصول للناس الذين يحتاجون مساعدات بشكل
مباشره اضافه الى ملايين الاشخاص الذين
سيزداد اعداؤهم لذا ما استمر هذا القتال
وان احتياجات الانسانيه ستزداد اكثر من
واشنطن مدير برنامج افريقيا في منظمه
شكرا جزيلا
في هذه الاثناء نقلت الامم المتحده معظم
موظفيها مؤقتا الى بورت سودان لكنها اكدت
انها لن تغادر السودان رغم المخاوف من
امتداد المعارك الى مناطق جديده
عن
هذه انا سعيد لاننا جميعا هنا بامان
قادمين من الخرطوم في رحله طويله جدا
لكننا فعلنا ذلك معا
واجهتنا بعض التحديات على الطريق ولم يكن
الجسر الجوي من الدرجه الاولى لكنني اعتقد
انه كان من الجيد اننا جميعا خرجنا
35 ساعه في قافله غير مريحه هي بالتاكيد
افضل من ثلاث ساعات من القصف والجلوس تحت
القذائف
ومع تسرع وتيره اجلاء الدبلوماسيين
والاجانب من السودان تباينت الطرق التي
تلجا اليها الحكومات لاجلاء رعاياها في ظل
صعوبات ومشاكل اللوجستيه توجهها على الارض
للتعرف اكثر على تلك الطرق نتابع التقرير
التالي
تعددت الطرق والهدف واحد الخروج من
السودان في اسرع وقت ممكن فاستمرار القتال
لليوم العاشر بين الجيش والدعم السريع دفع
عشرات الدول للمصارعه باجلاء رعاياها من
هناك ونظرا للتواصل الاشتباكات في محيط
مطار الخرطوم الدولي فان خيارات الاجلاء
المباشر لم تكن متاحه سوى للدول القادره
على اخراج مواطنيها ودبلوماسي ومن رافقهم
من رعايا دول صديقه عبر طائرات عسكريه تحط
لمده قصيره في العاصمه الخرطوم او مطارات
صغيره قريبه منها وهذا ما فعلته بريطانيا
عبر عمليه قالت انها كانت سريعه ومعقده
ومن قبلها الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
المستفيدتان من وجود قواعد عسكريه لهما في
جيبوتي كما شارك اكثر من الف جندي الماني
في اجلاء المئات من الاشخاص على متن
طائرات تابعه الجوي الالماني في حين ارسلت
دولا اوروبيه واسيويه طائرات عسكريه الى
جيبوتي لاجلاء مواطنيها بذات الطريقه لكن
حكومات دول اخرى اضطرت لاجلاء رعايه من
الاراضي السودانيه على عده مراحل تبدا
بنقلهم برا الى مناطق بعيده عن بؤر القتال
ثم اجلائهم من هناك عبر عده مسارات وقد
كانت مدينه بورتسودان الواقعه شمال شرقي
البلاد المحطه الاهم بالنسبه اليهم
فالوصول الى هناك اتاح لهم اكثر من خيار
لمغادره السودان فاما عبر البر الى
الاراضي المصريه كما فعل ذلك المصريون
ورعايا دول افريقيه او بحرا باتجاه ميناء
جده السعودي انطلاقا من ميناء بورتسودان
على الساحل الغربي للبحر الاحمر كما فعل
ذلك السعوديون ورعايا دول خليجيه واجنبيه
او جوا من مطار المدينه الى مطارات اخرى
لا سيما مطار جده ومطار القاهره المصري
ومطار عمان الاردني الذي وصل اليه المئات
من الرعايه الاردنيين ورعايه دول عربيه
واجنبيه بعد اجلائهم عبر طائرات تابعه
لسلاح الجو الاردني كما اخترت دولا
افريقيه نقل دبلوماسيين
جنوب الشرقي السودان تمهيدا لاجلائهم
لاحقا الى اثيوبيا عبر الطريق البري في
حين اكد مسؤولون في جنوب السودان ان
حدودهم الشماليه استقبلت العديد من
الرعايه الاجانب في انتظار اجلائهم لاحقا
الى دولهم عبر مطار جوبا
[موسيقى]